let's just say i did have it was i got
in my head
that um there was some trepidation
from the studio about whether we should
do this at all
and so i thought you know what we'll do
let's just do it at the house
or just like no no
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves how are you
we're great very good thank you how are
you debbie i'm sorry
i answered i'm good i thought you guys
would be in the same room
we are she's upstairs and we because
we've been it's hilarious
what does it feel like to be here zack
snyder's justice league is here what are
the emotions like right now zack
it's a bit of an exhale it's a bit of a
uh
um it's been quite a road as you can
imagine so
um yeah we're just uh drinking champagne
a lot
and um trying to enjoy it we just really
finished the last
version of the movie last week so i feel
like we've had our heads down
trying to get you know the enormous
amount of visual effects done
four hours of score with so little
time all doing it distance you know
during cobit
so i think finally now we can exact said
exhale take a deep breath
and um and enjoy it because it's been
quite a journey
we're also finishing our other movie our
army of the dead movie at the same time
so it's a little bit of a
so no breaks here no we're not real
breaks a little bit a little break
teeny bit yeah
i have a second chance i am not gonna
waste it
i didn't realize how down to the wire
you guys were um
so this is such an unprecedented
opportunity for fans to truly see
uh your vision and i know they were so
integral into getting this going
what was the most important thing for
you to get right
in zack snyder's justice league i think
uh
you know the most important thing to get
right was just the honesty of the movie
and just
be honest with the like the the stuff i
wanted to do and
my um sort of vision for the movie i
really wanted to
make it as much uh as uncompromised as i
could and that was the real
that was the real work we did is to get
back to
you know that that uh january 2017 cut
that i uh that i had prepared and that
now
you you kind of got to see uh
whatever this is however years later we
are now it's
i i thought it was so wonderful so
awesome i think one of the most
satisfying parts of the experience for
me was to see
ray fisher's cyborg get the emotional
fleshed-out story that he deserved all
along
how satisfying was it for you to bring
his backstory
to life the way that we were meant to
see it yeah i mean
you know when chris terrio and i even
from the beginning
when we talked about what justice league
would be it was always
a cyborg movie in a lot of ways because
we felt like it was he's an incredibly
important
dc character and we knew we had ray
so we knew we had a solid and amazing
actor to
flesh out these big big ambitious dreams
we had for
um what cyborg would do and uh we were
definitely
not surprised but overwhelmed by how
great he is
and how great the character does come
out um and i just
i couldn't be happier with uh with the
way the movie
with with his arc and you know the
completion of his story in the movie
it's really
it's really quite satisfying isn't that
right
batman i want to get into this new
nightmare scene that was added with
jared leto and ben affleck because you
had to like
call them and get them to come to your
backyard was it and film
a new scene like i i need to be walked
through this like
operation here walk me through it no
that was my original okay
let's just say i did have it was i got
in my head
that um there was some trepidation
from the studio about whether we should
do this at all
and so i thought you know what we'll do
let's just do it at the house
we'll just have it like no no
i mean we did you you know we we did
like eli and i my son who's here with us
we did do a couple little shots for the
movie here at the house
um but um yeah so that was my idea but
it was gonna be on a pretty big scale so
we were like okay well
maybe we shouldn't do that and then
luckily uh
you know warren brothers agreed uh to do
it hbo max
and uh so we got to shoot in a real
sound stage so
that was fun but it was it was still
super challenging because
we have to do it at a certain time to
get the visual effects done to make it
in the film
but all the actors weren't available at
the same time so we had to shoot
some of them separately and ezra was um
on fantastic beasts in england so zach
had to direct him over
zoom wow gosh well pulled off
wonderfully um just last question before
i go
there's a lot of cliffhangers a lot of
setup and i know the momentum is already
in motion for
restore the snyder verse what would it
take for you both to come back
and do more snyder verse experiences
like this one what would
you know my thing is that you know
warner brothers
um they're they're the gatekeepers and
they
you know it's i have huge respect for
their decision that they want to they've
made their own
they're on another track this movie's
three years old um
of course we we envisioned it as a
bigger thing but
if this is the final version of justice
league that anybody sees
you know that it we're quite happy it's
been such a journey
to get to this place and and it took so
much hard work
like from the fans to the crew that i
think right now
we just want to like savor the moment of
this because it's been years in the
making
yeah literally
you